waren es kriege epidemien oder aber lag
es an der fruchtbarkeit dass die
neandertaler vor rund 40.000 jahren von
der erde verschwanden die antwort ist
uns die forschung bis heute schuldig
geblieben und die gründe für das
verschwinden unserer eiszeitlichen
vetter weiterhin ein riesiges ungelöstes
rätsel
ein französisches forschungsteam hat
jetzt modellrechnungen dazu haben
gestellt und präsentiert einen
überraschenden erklärungsansatz warum
genau also sind unsere steinzeit cousins
ausgestorbenen fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
fest steht die neandertaler sind als
eigenständige menschenart vor rund
40.000 jahren ausgestorben das einzige
was von ihnen übrig geblieben ist ist
ein kleiner prozentsatz von ihnen im
erbgut des homo sapiens sie haben sich
also mit unseren vorfahren vermischt
doch was genau führt zu dem verschwinden
unserer steinzeit cousins dazu gibt es
viele verschiedene theorien wurden sie
etwa von unseren vorfahren ausgerottet
oder war eine massen epidemie der grund
für ihr verschwinden auch ein
klimawechsel wird manchmal als eine
mögliche ursache genannt klar ist nur
dass er verschwinden zeitgleich mit der
ankunft des modernen menschen dem homo
sapiens auf dem kontinent zusammenfiel
fachleute gehen zudem davon aus dass die
neandertaler zwar nicht mit einem schlag
ausgestorben sind dies jedoch innerhalb
einer relativ kurzen zeitspanne von etwa
10.000 jahren oder weniger passierte
laut der anthropologin silvana kondome
aus frankreich ist dies ein argument
gegen das aussterben aufgrund eines
ausrottung des krieges zwischen unseren
vorfahren und den neandertalern ihr
aussterben in mittlerer geschwindigkeit
spricht zudem auch gegen epidemien oder
einen anstieg der erwachsenen oder
kindersterblichkeit als ursache ein
französisches forschungsteam hat jetzt
einige erklärungsansätze in
modellrechnungen genauer durchgespielt
dafür haben die fachleute verschiedene
parameter mit in ihrer analyse
einbezogen unter anderem daten zur
migration und fruchtbarkeit raten von
modernen jäger und sammler gruppen
großen
und die datenlage auf bereits
existierenden studien zu neandertalern
demnach könnte das aussterben dieser
gattung dadurch begründet sein dass die
fruchtbarkeitsrate bei den jungen
neandertalerin über mehrere tausend
jahre hinweg leicht zurückgegangen ist
laut silvana condomi passt dieser
erklärungsansatz zunehmen relativ kurzen
zeitraum ihres aussterbens demnach sei
der rückgang der fruchtbarkeitsrate zwar
sehr gering aber erreicht über einen
langen zeitraum um den neandertaler
aussterben zu lassen so condomi die
fachleute spekuliert ob dabei indirekt
auch die ankunft des homo sapiens eine
rolle gespielt haben könnte
denkbar sei es beispielsweise dass
unsere vorfahren konkurrenten bei der
nahrungssuche gewesen sein die aufnahme
von weniger kalorien kann nämlich
negative einflüsse auf schwangerschaften
haben um diesen neuen erklärungsansatz
zu untermauern sind aber weitere fossile
funde unabdingbar von diesen existieren
derzeit nur sehr wenige was die
forschung in diesem bereich extrem
erschwert erst anfang des jahres hatte
ein paläontologie team einen fossilen
fußabdruck in die breite entdeckt der
möglicherweise von einem neandertaler
stammen könnte mehr krieg so gibt es ab
sofort bei pixum nature bitte abonniert
den kanal hier hier drauf kriegen und
unterstützt mich dabei umweltthemen hier
auf youtube mehr zu verbreiten vielen
vielen dank bis dann bleibt dran